I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to another
edition of ask Evan today i'm answering
a question from one of my newsletter
subscribers i think named michael who
are insane he runs he's part of the
insurance company we need him to a list
of experts that we feature on twitter
and his question was about a company who
was in his industry a blog written by
one of his competitors that is a hater
of the company and he wanted my feedback
and how to respond to it and he thought
that the messages would be good press
for him and displayed the lack of class
of the competition but i wanted my
thoughts and feelings so Michael went to
go check out the blog and this is a site
here I didn't see anything negative
about your company here and so maybe
that's because I'm a little late in
getting this video back to you so my
apologies for that I wasn't quite sure
if they were if they were specifically
harping on your company or just in the
industry in general two responses one in
any sure you're going to have people who
are haters and who you know might even
lie or feed misinformation just to try
to get clients and my response there's
just try to be a force for good you know
think about the people you're trying to
serve try to be a thought leader try to
have your own voice and create your own
content and articles and interviews and
videos and educate your customers as
much as you can about the problems that
they're facing and how you know you can
put that your help solve them for them
but just be a resource and try to be
that force for good that your customers
look forward to hearing from you and you
become the trusted voice in your
industry and I think it's not too hard
to do that if you are you know authentic
and you're sharing your knowledge and
that's what I try to deal with these
YouTube videos I started doing it
because people were asking me questions
and I felt sometimes the easiest way to
respond would be just to make a youtube
video but also there be other people
have the same questions and hopefully I
can help the personal ask the question
as well as everybody else in my tune in
and watch and so it just came from a
desire to help entrepreneurs and
hopefully you know in your business you
have a strong desire to
your clients it sounds like it and you
know just just try to be that force for
good and share your knowledge and be a
resource I don't know for this company
and if they're these guys are the haters
and that's not spending more time on
them and maybe go back through email
there but in any in any business you're
going to have people who are not your
supporters and who don't like you for
whatever reason it may not be rational
at all and in general I think as
entrepreneurs we try to try to be
optimistic try to be positive and it's
and as much as possible at least for me
I try to ignore the haters and not spend
too much time with negative energy just
because it doesn't it's not productive
it just drags you down and doesn't help
you at all and here's an example so the
company is is doing something negative
against you I again just probably say
ignore them and try to focus on
something more positive example for my
background I do a lot of these YouTube
videos and again it's just trying to
help entrepreneurs try to share my
advice and be resource where I can I had
a question come in from somebody I
believe his name was Joe but it was
about how to sell life insurance he was
struggling to sell life insurance and
wanted my advice and what to do and so
created this quick video and I'm on a
whiteboard I'm talking about it and
we've had thirteen thousand views on it
and 169 thumbs ups and one thumbs down
so thank you for everybody to give it a
thumbs up I always appreciate those and
that we had a lot of comments on here so
most of them are always good and in
general the comments are great so thanks
for sharing your idea very informative
and helpful it was yesterday two days
ago wash it three times that's great i
try to respond so guys if you do leave a
comment i'll try to give it a response
as much as I can but a little while ago
so we had 33 comments so while ago we
had a guy named Sam there is Sam so Sam
I probably wasn't one to get the one
thumbs down out of the 169 thumbs ups um
he wrote Evan take the marbles out of
your mouth your ideas suck now I don't
know Sam I don't know if he's watching
the other videos and what his beef was
movies maybe work woke up on the wrong
side of bed but you know when you see a
negative comment come in like that it it
always
you think about it you know you always
kind of focus a little bit more on the
negatives and on all the positives that
come in but I try not to let those
things get me down too much I just
responded to Sam with a simple thanks
Sam and gave him a wink and that was the
end of it I didn't want to get into some
long discussion about why I'm ideas
don't suck her you know looking at his
channel and giving him some kind of
negative comment it's just it's not
productive it drags you down it doesn't
make you feel good and I'd rather focus
my energies on something more positive
and something that I love doing so that
was my quick response I didn't hear back
from him I didn't write anything else to
him and one of my my fans stood in and
also said Sam your loser if you're going
to hate don't watch the videos and so I
thanked him as well for always for
appreciating the support there and so
yeah again just focus on the positive be
a force for good try not to let that one
issue or one negative comment from from
a competitor especially get you down and
one thing that I find always helps me is
looking at the feedback that I get for
my customers and my users and I get that
in the form of the YouTube comments
every day I get comments on the channel
and they're overwhelmingly positive and
that that you know makes me feel good
that I'm helping people and want to do
more of these videos so hopefully you
can look at some of the feedback from
your customers that they're providing
you and that that lets you know that hey
you know what you're doing a good job
you're doing the right thing and not let
those guys who want to hate get you down
so hopefully that helps Michael for
those are you watching if you liked the
video please give it a thumbs up below I
always appreciate those and I'd love to
hear what you have to think hopefully
it's positive about the video or if you
have a question about your own business
I'd love to be able to try to answer for
you so thank you and I'll see you on the
next episode
you